[Music]
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
like a heifer to the slouch we starting
did did we started
all right [ __ ]
he goes he goes we're recording
so [ __ ] chilling
so what are we gonna do dude well it's
[ __ ] lifeline episode 19.
actually this is the first time i really
don't know there we go see we're getting
up there
19 19 dude 19. uh so that's it and we're
we're doing it and you've got your blue
chips hat on and christian leighton was
in blue chips and so was shaquille
o'neal you know what else i got
this shirt it's not a shirt that's a rag
which is that's a wrap a bit falling
apart but check it out
i'm retiring it today oh this is it for
this show the last time i'm ever gonna
wear it
for obvious reasons
should have definitely retired it way
way earlier than that it looks like you
got in fight with many many bobcats you
can see my tattoos
yeah okay well it's all good uh that's a
horrible [ __ ] shirt uh
what was it less
um
was it less in the in the pool
was it was it less uh
ripped earlier oh yeah well no i didn't
buy it like this but i mean it looks so
perfectly ripped like it's so weird
there's just like holes in it so it had
small holes all over but you know when
you put on a shirt with small holes in
it
you put your arm in too fast the worst
type of the worst time you rip it out
yeah you put the look at the hole in the
middle i'd like to talk to you about
shirts oh wow crazy so you know what it
looks like you have turned you kind of
turned you went to turn into the hulk
and then kind of gave up halfway yeah
that sounds about right for me and my
personality actually um so yeah so we're
downtown we're coming to you live from
downtown los angeles at our lifeline
studio at our supercode studios we are
doing the show lifeline and i brought my
son down here with me and he's chilling
in the studio so it's very cool so if
you hear some stuff like
in the back that's calvin okay i hear it
now yeah but they won't but he's he's
drawing um
he's drawing uh daddy pig what's that
what
daddy pig yeah he's drawing daddy pig
okay so peppa pig is a is a cartoon
and daddy pig is the dad in the cartoon
and that's his favorite one in peppa pig
style he does love peppa pig i knew yeah
oh there's the video right there it is
we'll show it maybe we'll put it up uh
at the end of the show give it to me uh
give it to me i'll show you give it to
me give me that funk that sweet that
nasty that gushy stuff the [ __ ]
nope
so that was so bad nope so this is what
calvin did dude
[Music]
this going to be on the internet he's
good at it oh okay he he take it back he
did daddy pig
um george georgie pig that's peppa pig
and that's mama pig you know how many
drawings i've seen that are better than
this yeah but dude he's two and a half
okay i'm just saying it's really good
for two and a half you don't need to
drudge it on a sliding scale just
for a sake of the art this is bad no
it's good it's abstract he does abstract
[ __ ] all right so what about my hat i
bought this at a seven o'clock a video
game hat a hat that just dude there is
not a hat that somebody who doesn't
speak english would wear more than that
i mean i love it because i'm a mr
adventurer they when you when you went
to purchase it at the gas station they
looked at you and they and they
literally thought but you're not mexican
like that's what they thought well they
could think i'm mexican first of all i
don't look
i don't look unmexican are you unmexican
dude do you know what you know you know
what you're either a mexican or a
mexican
in [ __ ] johnny what's that movie uh
what is it
before the devil knows you're mexico
once upon a time in mexico no no neither
one of them i mean the worst titles of
all time uh once the devil knows you're
mexico
you're the mexican american it's the
[ __ ] robert rodriguez follow-up to
desperado what's it called something
something mexico
i was right yeah you didn't say once
upon a time i did no he didn't what did
he say i said that second i said
uh uh before the devil knows you're me
yeah he did not before the devil knows
your mexico then i said
once upon a time in mexico a guy who
says before the devil knows where mexico
would get that hat because they don't
speak english yeah well i'm wearing it
so anyway do that so it's all good um so
anyway dude i mean retiring this shirt
just don't even wear a shirt you know so
what are you gonna do with that shirt
afterwards wash your car it's gonna be a
rag you know burn it ceremoniously i
would say though you probably don't wash
your car because that the guy who wears
a shirt like that doesn't keep his car
clean also i i definitely do not wash my
car there we go and i'm a detective baby
oh [ __ ] he figured it out yeah or you
need to crack just do that talk to what
or you just knew that about me
ruin it i also seem like a detective
dude too many hats too many water
bottles all good dude you gotta have
backups
back up hats if you don't like the way
one hat's looking on you feeling on you
you gotta you got it in rotation you got
another hat if you don't like the way
this is a song calvin would listen to
you if you don't like the way one hat
looks you put on another hat if you
don't like the way it feels
such a bad song
tony bennett after he lost his mind tony
bennett with dementia
such a bad song if you don't like one
hat put on another
if you don't like the way one feels
okay
you might like the way the other one
feels
wow forgot the words well that's what
tony bennett does okay uh you want to
get right into it dude
whatever you want yeah let's do it let's
get into some [ __ ] advices dude this
is lifeline you're either a mexican or
likes a kent okay uh before the devil
knows you're mexico so bad and so uh so
that's what's up so all right so and
then also i'm gonna be in dallas dude
this is let's do this last like one of
the last times i'm going to say this
before i'm in dallas i don't believe
that uh i'm going to be in dallas i'm
going to be in wichita and i'm going to
be in atlanta and washington d.c and
savannah georgia go to crystalia.com to
get tickets and that's to see your boy
live live in the flesh and uh you'll see
me and i might not see you unless you're
in the first two rows because it's shiny
and that's why we were on travis scott's
side
let's get into it wow
hey matt hey chris i have a question for
you um i'm a golf coach over the summer
um for a kid's camp and i'm paired with
a head golf pro
and he's super nice he's like my dad's
age like super friendly but he's been
doing some things i don't know if he's
like trying to flirt with me like just a
good guy
he'll like buy me lunch we'll like split
it talk about golf he bought me like two
really expensive like golf clubs to like
improve my game
he's been wanting to do like private
lessons
with me which like i need to work on my
golf game and also this sunday he
invited me to go golfing with him and a
client and then he invited me for drinks
after
so i don't know if he's just being like
a friendly nice guy or if like he
is like trying to flirt
thanks let me know what you guys think
hey
quick question where's your brain
dude it's a sign 40 signs but she's
doing the ones that when she says hey
are you doing this he can say no no no
which which i don't like now [ __ ] it's
gonna be
given signs be more overt and obvious
don't do the ones where you can be like
i was just being
like [ __ ]
yeah whoa
i don't like that [ __ ] yeah either i
don't like that either that's the worst
kind of guy dude yeah but but also if
you do do be our overtly hopefully
you're not famous because that can come
bite you in the ass snaper so anyway
what you do is so what you do is
you realize now immediately that we're
telling you it's a sign
ah jesus it's a sign he's definitely
dude this is the question if he was
doing this
if he was doing this with
a
dude would it be gay
um
no not well whatever necessarily not not
but you would definitely think is this
guy gay no because it's like
the age factor makes me think it could
be like a mentor mentee thing
i'm not trying to defend the guy but it
doesn't sound like anything he's doing
is like across any kind of line it's not
it's not but it's not it's not but he's
like he's like you know she's like well
you know what he bought me two really
expensive golf clubs you know he took me
to a client with golf and then he took
me out to drinks afterwards i just don't
know you know he went back to his
apartment i'm just not sure he hit some
candles when i was walked in the candles
were all lit i'm just not sure if and
then when i was laying down in his bed
and he entered me i just don't know he
thrust it a few times and i'm just like
kind of like is this like work
he proposed he had a ring and he
proposed you know i have i'm pregnant
i'm big with a child
that's what they said in the tutors
i'm watching the tudors and the dad said
to amber lynn when you're big with
childhood
so rude such a rude ass way to put it
said your daughter dude you know when
you're big with child it's it's it's
common for the man to look elsewhere
that's what he said well
big with child dude
so misogynist dude
big
you're big with child yeah you're just
big you might as well say fat at that
point
yeah big is actually ruder than fat yeah
yeah when you're fat with child
when you are plump with child
when you are
[ __ ] look like you can roll down a
hill with child wow you know the worst
idea when pregnant
when
what i don't like is when people write
those shows the tutors
yeah when they don't they didn't live
back then and they're just kind of
guessing what they sounded like you know
that there's ways to research it kind of
but you don't really know like like i
sort of got one on one show the tutor
jonathan rhys meyer said come on man he
did yeah i'm not [ __ ] well that's
not that seems like a s and then they
say stuff like i mean um and it's like
did they say i mean
come on what they say i mean did they
like dot dot oh yeah what
they said i mean and then come on man
i mean come on i mean come on man what
are you talking about in one time and
one time the [ __ ] ambulance dad she
goes i'm pregnant and he says it's lit
[Music]
what's amber lin ann bolin is the woman
and bolin yeah okay i thought you were
saying
something wrong ambulance
entertainment ambulance all right cool
so yeah he's definitely trying to donk
you all good been the [ __ ] problem
since the beginning of time but he's
doing this stuff that he's gonna be like
whoa whoa whoa
whoa
i'm just getting you a drink
chill i didn't know it was gonna be all
like that and then he's gonna definitely
say like something like you stuck up
[ __ ] like that's what those guys do
that's what those dudes do i was just
trying to be a friend
you stuck up [ __ ] i don't think she's
gonna say that if she calls him out on
that don't make her think she's really
gonna say he might think it
but
is it worth bringing here's the thing i
think what you have to weigh is
is it worth bringing i know this is not
what she's asking should i bring it up
with them she's asking is that what this
is i think it probably is that yeah but
you have to weigh personally if it's
worth bringing up
obviously he hasn't quite crossed any
lines but obviously if he does you do
need to bring it up but he's playing in
that gray zone which we don't approve of
but
it's not you have to decide if it's
worth calling them out on it or not you
know it's it might not be there yet yeah
it depends just [ __ ] watch out you'll
be big with child yeah with him
yeah
big with child
when you're big with child it's common
for a man to step out on his mistress
but you need to pick his mistress so you
can control it like the stress that was
in the tudors was unbelievable the
stress back then is unbelievable dude
what do you mean the stress like the
fact that people used to live in the
1400s and be like oh god am i gonna say
something that's gonna result in it
counting as treason and then i got to
have my head lopped off yeah that's so
you know what i mean the stakes were
higher also the life expectancy was like
12. i know yeah but also henry viii
would be like say i'm more important
than the king otherwise you can be
locked up forever right and then you're
like oh but you even believe that he's
not more important than the church like
who gives a [ __ ] like pride was
something yeah probably much more
something than it is now yeah i'd rather
die for my church than living you know
what i mean it's like what yeah stop
right there dude people were willing
much more willing to die back then than
they are now and all they wanted to do
was be big with child and keep on moving
the the race all right let's do it okay
by the way he's okay right talking like
hey chris and matt
okay he's good okay good
let's do it
hey kristen matt big fan of the show i
think you guys are awesome hell yeah uh
keep doing what you're doing uh quick
just quick here this guy burke thinks
he's my boss he isn't tries to
micromanage me
it's starting to get to me i'm biting my
tongue for weeks now and i'm just i'm
this [ __ ] close from snapping
and i don't know if i should confront
him i don't know if i should go to my
boss and say hey listen i'm sick of this
[ __ ] guy um
he he just he he texts me throughout the
day he won't even like confront me in
person about it he'll text me because
he's too much of a [ __ ]
uh so i don't know i just i don't know
if i should confront him and get get in
his face like i don't want to like cause
a fight but i mean like i'm i am a
groomsman i'm sick of this [ __ ] guy
right so i don't know any advice would
help tell me what i should do
thanks guys oh i would well i'll tell
you what i would do 100 is it absolutely
block his number
like that's so annoying i'd block his
number and then when he came up he'd be
like why are my texts green and i would
say oh look at that a conversation
right i mean that's horseshit but i
think you don't want to give him
ammunition to get you in trouble with
your boss you want to be in the right
when it is presented to your actual boss
when it comes to that i think what you
really want to do
is confront him but don't like not when
you're ready to snap
bring it up when he doesn't actually do
it bring it up independently and so you
can have some kind of objective setting
be like you know you're not really the
boss i don't know why you sort of
whatever it is give me orders whatever
whatever you know and then if that
doesn't work then you go to the boss you
don't want to go straight to the boss
because then you're kind of
making it maybe more of an issue than it
has to be if you can just confront the
guy directly look him in the eye don't
look away don't look down
and when he tells you go hey
make sure it's like
right if you need to just take his
actual head and manipulate his head yeah
hold it like this and say it like this
cause you're struggling that might be a
little bit of a problem in the workplace
so yeah maybe but you know and then and
then what and then or you what you can
do is be like hey come with me to the
dude and then
you know
it's gonna be so bad no no this is this
really works okay so you know walk him
over to the office to the boss's office
right and the boss is sitting there and
the bus goes guys i'm busy what's going
on he's like i just got him come here
dude and you're closing you're gonna
point point to the boss's
butt and say
who who's whose ass is that
and when the guy goes what and it goes i
don't have time for this no boss excuse
me that's very important whose ass is
that yeah
and then he says that's the boss's ass
and he'd be like oh dude that's why
you're not sitting with your ass in the
boss's chair yeah
oh [ __ ] dude because he's the boss right
and that's why his ass is in the boss's
chair yeah yeah that's good because it's
very clear yeah yeah be like so then
don't tell me what to do right and then
yeah and spin move okay
on the spin move you know yeah
no no but i'm saying you have to have
this one because and also you can get oh
dude i've been wearing mine
have you been wearing yours like a good
little boy or a bad little boy
have you been a naughty little boy
have you been a nasty naughty
scummy little boy so weird so weird or
have you been a good boy i'm i mean you
know
so weird to look in your brother's eyes
and say that [ __ ] so so weird
[ __ ] my i mean dude come on dude i'm
being with child i'm all about the weird
[ __ ] you know
yeah honestly have you been a naughty
nasty little boy no i haven't been i've
been a good little boy
no i have been either one oh you've been
a [ __ ] cool man
[Laughter]
all right
i've been a good little boy okay
okay all right so let's go to the next
one
hey chris matt love the show love what
you're you're doing uh you guys
compliment each other so much it's a
great show thank you uh and podcast i
guess anyway i was seeing an advice on
managing my
how to manage how you speak to others i
think you guys probably are about the
same as me and the fact that
we kind of say how it is we're really
honest we're blind it's black and white
that's what we need that's what we want
and people sometimes take that
offensively especially lately my spouse
oh uh
not quite sure what you guys do with
that especially chris you know you have
your spouse and matt with the dogs how
do you not offend them with um telling
them your needs and managing your
expectations
let me know and it's uh
it's always work in progress but what
are your tips and tricks for that dude i
wish that uh there was a show that was
not our show that i could call into with
this um
because i have a tone apparently
i have a tone
and no matter what i say and even if i
try to not do the tone
i still do it
stop and um maybe i should sing it no no
i think uh
this is this is hard you didn't mean
stop
all right go ahead this is hard because
i think you two apparently but any
relationship and i do it you cut me off
no you cut me off i know but you're
adding to it but yeah um so i think any
relationship that you or i have been in
we've run into a version of this problem
which is
it's it's all it's baked into our sense
of humor yes the the purse not the
person not like where this separate
thing from who we actually are but it's
it's like a sty manner of speaking and a
whole kind of sense of humor that is
aligned in this one way that the tone of
voice can come out jagged sometimes to
people that are not as familiar with it
as
we are and that completely makes sense
first of all
but it's also hard for either one of us
to just change the way we talk to people
that we're close with because we talk
the way we that we talk and i think the
partner that one of us has at any given
time will tell us but you at least can
talk differently to me now that is a
misconception because that is [ __ ]
hard yeah to speak to everyone right the
same way and then one person a different
way so there has to be and this is my
advice to you when this comes up there
has to be some sort of meeting halfway
of like
i understand that my tone of voice can
be harsh yeah
but i need you to understand that the
way you're hearing it is not always the
the level uh hold the cough for what i'm
done that's why i heard it
but
uh we need to sort of figure out a way
to meet halfway spouse they're married
obviously this is something they have to
figure out yeah and i think the way to
do it is to explain that
like clearly without being angry and
then get
she didn't specify if she's married to a
man or woman but let's say it's a he
if he's like i mean she's married to him
man you know but it's usually it's
usually the other way around though is
why i say that
yeah you know the one married to a woman
yeah the ones with the right voice
problem when she said that i was like
wow this dude's tripping exactly so
maybe she's married a woman who knows
um
but anyone's big with child then she's
more emotional okay but that's true
uh
that's my advice what do you think uh
yeah you have to like i mean well i will
tell you this much like yeah it is it is
baked into our [ __ ] yeah personality
because it's
yeah yeah and our family growing up like
our family would be like that's how we
honestly that's how we showed love we
would make fun of each other and then
laugh all together and then when you do
that with somebody who had a [ __ ] bad
childhood then this is not kristin she
had a great childhood but like
but like it's like and they all they
know is
chaos and then you're like yeah well you
know it's because you're fat not that i
would ever say that right but like you
wouldn't say that but like but like that
turns into
um
a trigger moment for them so it's this
constant balance and it sucks but yeah
you definitely have to have that
conversation whereas like look i will
definitely be more mindful with how i
speak to you and you just have to trust
that because sometimes i'll go in and
i'll be more mindful you know it depends
on what the [ __ ] mood they're in you
know sometimes kristen's in a [ __ ]
beautiful mood i could say something she
laughs sometimes she's not in a good
mood i'll say something that i think is
funny and it's not you know it doesn't
get over uh it's not perceived well so
um which is crazy because i'm a comedian
and what i say and if i if i say it's
funny you should be funny right because
and so um
so i'll say it's a joke but that it
hurts your feelings you know it's a
whole thing whatever and it's not a big
deal but
what i should what you should say is
like i'm gonna try and do that but like
just please like understand that this is
the way i talk because otherwise it's
like dude thank god you're not dating a
russian
like you would just you'd be like oh
well this guy's an [ __ ] the whole
time you know what i can do it leads to
different facial expressions and i get a
whole smorgasbord
i mean i'm practically on the [ __ ]
i'm all the guys from guess who you know
what i mean like you look at me i could
do smile i could do surprise i could do
[ __ ] pissed off i can do oh
bewildered i can do all that [ __ ] so can
everyone no no russians don't do that
dude well i have a question about
mcdonald's in the russian in the rush
when mcdonald's reached russia they
almost [ __ ] up everything because the
mcdonald's whole thing was serviced with
a smile and then the russians were like
here it's your stuff and russia was like
what the hell is all this stuff why are
you smiling you want something from me
so i have a question about russians
they sound angry and mean in their own
language to us who don't speak their
language
and when they speak in uh with their
accent in english yes
do they sound mean to each other yes in
their native language yeah but that's
how they do it it's like we're talking
to each other in our family that's what
they do that's how they do so it's like
that with everyone if you're if you
greet somebody in russia with a smile
yeah that is considered like weird like
oh you must want something from me no
i've what yeah they're like what is this
you're trying to get one oh dude that is
such a weird you don't smile unless
you're actually happy you know how like
you you beat this this is true about
mcdonald's the whole service you made no
no no when it first got over there in
like the 70s or something
it was a whole thing russians were like
let's go see what this is like with us
where they smile what the hell yeah [ __ ]
100 and i know that because i'm smart no
well then why do i know that because you
saw something on the tv once and it
stuck with you all right
you gave in you know no i read it okay
okay google you know and looked it up on
youtube okay but yeah so uh anyway so
just basically the whole thing is you
know
this is not really anyone's fault except
it's kind of his fault like he needs to
get with the [ __ ] program yeah like
she didn't mean it [ __ ] but she can't
tell him that i know she can't we'll
[ __ ] tune in here buddy hey buddy
relax right dude you're married for
[ __ ] sake she doesn't hate you yeah
yeah wow maybe it does
i do understand though dude i i
understand it's hard people communicate
in different ways their whole lives and
they meet when they're adults and they
got these different styles it's true
about how you express love too like
there are these different love languages
it's right that's also with actual
language people speak differently and
they have their whole life totally
totally so it's hard like somebody
figure it out you know somebody might be
like don't fart around me that's bad and
then another guy everyone's yeah but
when i do that i'm open with it i'm open
with you and that's because i love you
wow your ass is open that's for sure but
also it's different for
it's different for men and women right
like
if you were like if somebody like if if
if my significant other was gonna say
something that made me feel bad right
and i would be like oh that makes me
feel bad and then they would be like
oh
well i didn't mean that and then i would
be like all right and then like three
minutes later i'd be like let's get
pizza but if you do that the other way
around
like if i say some [ __ ] to my
significant other i'm not talking about
kristen this is very general but like
and then i say like something that is
deemed to be assholey and then she's
like oh what the [ __ ] you know you did
that i'm like oh [ __ ] my bad i didn't
mean to do that she'd be like okay and
then for [ __ ] a day and a half she's
gonna be like i just you know i don't
know it was just the way you snapped and
you leave it snap right so it's like
well what the [ __ ] so it's hard to deal
with so my point is it is different
since you're the female in this
situation and you know i guess you might
be a female that you're married to but
um
yeah i don't know it's a tough it's a
tough thing but have that conversation
of hey i know exactly
i know what you're saying and i'm going
to try to be aware of this
now make me a sandwich you [ __ ] fat
piece of [ __ ] wow that's not a good uh
way to wrap up the advice do all that
except the last very last thing chris
said okay now a word from our sponsor
betterhelp who we love
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
that's how our brains work so why don't
we treat them that way yeah people don't
think about this uh and they really
should you need to keep up with your
mental okay i do that uh better help is
a great thing to do that you go to
betterhelp.com just uh with better you
can do a better help or therapy in
general honestly it's great um so it
helps me it keeps me kind of at bay dude
therapy has helped me for years and
years and i've actually tried better
help and it's truly truly amazing yeah
it's been life-changing honestly yeah uh
and uh just lifts my honestly list my
spirits overall which is uh and it makes
you better in situations you don't feel
so good in it does feel like a sure
superpower in a lot of ways yeah you
know uh better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat only therapy sessions so you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to which is uh which is a
huge thing i know a lot of times people
get nervous about it so you don't have
to be seen it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy over at
betterhelp and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours that's very
quick it's a lot quicker than having to
go sit with someone see if they work go
to another one see if they work that
could take months honestly the wait
lists for in-person therapy sometimes in
certain areas of the country are
months and months and months and months
this you can match with somebody at 48
hours so look better help is great our
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com lifeline so if you
support the show and you want some uh
some therapy here you go to better help
that's b e t t e r better
h e l p dot com slash lifeline that's
better h-e-l-p dot-com slash lifeline
do it
next aroni so i'm 25 and i've never
started been on a date i've never been
on a dinner date gone out with someone
to the movies bowling the whole dating
thing really whatever i mostly like to
stay inside i like my alone time you
know i never felt that need to have that
kind of relationship to have someone be
a part of my life and
me be part of their life in some way
that thought kind of scared me but i do
feel like we're watching later i'll
probably have to go out there and try
and meet someone but i just don't know
died die but i just don't know back
you can give to me and some other first
ever daters out there i mean shout out
to pearl jam
yeah i mean he went to the future and
saved humanity when he did it yeah yeah
yeah go to go to the go to the part
where he saved humanity please go to the
part we saved humanity i [ __ ] think
that this kind of [ __ ] is so funny and
also
why are we watching a podcast
why does he have a [ __ ] microphone
why does like well it's also cut
together the guy's obviously pro and so
i'm 25 and i've never
been on a date i've never been on a
dinner date gotten out someone to the
movies bowling the whole dating thing
really ever i mostly like to stay inside
i like my alone time you know i never
felt that need to have that kind of
relationship to have someone be a part
of my life and
me be part of their life in some way
that thought kind of scared me but i do
feel that sooner or later i'll probably
have to go out there and try and meet
someone but i just don't know
up up saved humankind saved humankind in
the year 3000.
that was great for several days dude it
recorded it so many times and that when
that
saw his cat like spill something and
then had to be like i can't record this
again and then just keep going dude um
honestly and this has been the podcast
depression with zach pimbro or whatever
the [ __ ] um
the podcast depression zack pimbro
zach pimbro i don't know does it sound
uh
well he's never been on a date and he's
25. welcome to depressing with zach
pimbro um so i would like to talk about
this now um my uh nuts have never
descended wow uh you know i would like
to have two nuts at this end i'm the
kind of guy that sits down and when i do
i don't have to worry about sitting on
my nuts because they're still inside me
uh and i
nuts descended you know
oh i'm just curious if you have um
if you have people on your planet with i
mean people who
so
hello this is zack pimbro um
what the [ __ ] do we have to say to this
guy welcome to the podcast depression
with zach pimbro um
i don't have a house i i uh i sleep in
the dirt
this is depression um he he he's never
been on my senses he doesn't want to be
on dates
i don't know man it's hard for some guys
he could be an intel
but he doesn't have an insult vibe at
all
i mean these cells are usually like
online and be like
yeah i mean anything's possible they all
deserve to die yeah yeah
yeah welcome to the podcast depression
what's that pimbro um uh but i mean what
tips to be someone who dates exist in
the world and be sociable like that's it
just i guess
if you want to be doing the apps right
yeah do the apps if you want a quick fix
get a hat with a feather in it and just
walk around people say something
they'll be like what's a nice hat some
chick some [ __ ] chick i mean she
might be a behemoth but who knows she
[ __ ] some chick will be like what's
up with that hat and then you'll be like
hi i actually have a podcast uh it's
called you may have heard it it's called
depression so wait you think he should
get a if you're gonna have the federal
government start walking in it you're
set you're doing dating if you do it
enough you will get somebody to be like
okay but there are easier ways like
tinder
what's easier than getting a hat with a
feather in it
no because you have to reach people that
way
if you just get a hab with a feather on
it and then go to the [ __ ] glendale
galleria and walk around some [ __ ]
chick she might be a behemoth but why do
you keep
qualifying with she might be what i'm
saying is that 10 isn't going to come up
to you and be like what's up with that
hat a 10 is going to be like weirdo with
the [ __ ] feather in his hat i think
everyone's going to be like weirdo what
the [ __ ] heather no job there's going
to be some job of the woman that comes
up why does she have to be so big
she might be making withdrawal
uh
oh [ __ ] i think that you'd
it's such a vague broad question i think
what you need to do is just be more
social if you want to be someone who's
dating go out into the world and speak
to people then you'll get at least
practice it doesn't even have to be a
woman with a with your eye on some kind
of romantic situation just get out there
and talk and also get on a [ __ ]
dating app you want to get on a dating
app for sure yeah i mean i can't believe
they've never been on a date or you know
what you do here's what you do this is
what you pre you practice and by
practice i mean you go to a movie by
yourself and you sit next to a girl
she might already be on a date with
someone else just sit on the other side
and just hold her hand and just feel
like feel what that feels like and
you're watching you're watching [ __ ]
beast with idris elba and you just look
over to her so just acting like
like and when she laughs like
[Laughter]
such a creepy
the microphone guys are man what the
[ __ ] are you from depression
zach pimbro
pimbro dude wow
uh all right yeah i mean that i think
that's gonna do it for that guy yeah i
mean just [ __ ] get out there get a
feather get a hat with a feather in it
okay and get on apps okay first get on
apps then do the hat with the feather
like wait wait i can't wait to see a
follow-up video if you've gotta have a
feather in it so it's really not working
um
i like how he cut it together and then
also overlaid his audio sometimes it's
just facial expressions i like steven
soderbergh directed it i liked it too
right all right let's go yeah so let's
go to the next one another one and
another one
hey matt hey chris love you guys so much
so the issue that i'm dealing with is i
have an older brother
and unfortunately i had to cut him out
of my life about two years ago he was
just verbally abusive to me he'd yell at
me in public
like crazy [ __ ] like that and it came to
a point where
i had to remove myself from this
situation because it was just so
unhealthy and
he has now reached out to me saying that
he loves me and he misses me
and that he wants to talk
so i'm wondering
do i open up that door to like have a
conversation and maybe
thinking that he will apologize for all
the nasty stuff he's done to me
i'm not really sure what to do you know
i listen to your podcast and i
hear how much fun you're having with
each other and i really wish that i had
that kind of relationship with my
sibling but i don't and that breaks my
heart a little bit so i need some help
thanks guys
um i think you gotta at least hear him
out meet with him and if he says he
wants to change and that he's sorry and
you feel safe and comfortable with that
uh i say give him a chance but don't you
know
don't let him slip right back into being
the way he was when you worked up the
courage to get him out of your life just
because we want someone to change
doesn't mean that they're going to and
it doesn't mean we should give them
endless chances to do so giving someone
like a brother a sister a parent a child
a chance to
become
better to be better to be the person
that you want them to be in your life
that they think they can be in your life
that's a good thing but
there's like a fine line uh or like a
there's like a line that you can cross
that is just you know you're being too
forgiving or you're being too harsh i
think give him a chance
let's see what he says if it's up to
snuff try it out and then if he does it
again the [ __ ] that you don't like
tell him look i gave you a chance this
is just who you are though and i can't
handle this [ __ ]
i mean your nipple is out
giving that like sage nice advice well
sometimes i'm just out sometimes when
you give advice your nipple's out yeah
at the beach
no
on a show like that you know you always
give them a second your nipples like
this
yeah my nipple's saying what's up um i
think that you're right but i also think
that uh
you should uh
before you even meet be like
what's different and what work have you
done you know what i mean like he should
be i don't know how bad it got or what
but like you know
if if that was me verbally being like
[ __ ] you if he's i don't know what he's
saying like but in public that's a lot
so
you know i would be like all right well
i gotta get into therapy and [ __ ]
figure this out if i oh the clock marco
uh i gotta figure this out i gotta be
you know ain't uh figure out my anger
problems you know so if he's doing
something about it then and if he's
actively like you know i know i [ __ ]
up let's meet then
good then do it then then i think you
meet
um
but uh if not
then i would be wary and maybe like a
you know it's also different between
meeting in person and also being on the
phone if he's like look i just have some
stuff i want to get off my chest and
that's a phone conversation
uh but if he's like you know i've really
thought about this long and hard and um
i want to you know
i don't want to do this i i've started
looking into like
being in therapy and like my anger
um is um
[Music]
my anger is uh is is you know whatever
it is it's it's affecting my life and
it's affecting people i love but get the
guy on betterhelp.com dude yeah yeah
nice tie-in yeah yeah sure
betterhelp.com is awesome and uh it's
simple and easy and so you know whereas
finding a therapist can be hard but but
but this guy no i genuinely mean it like
it's it's like the bare minimum sit on
your couch and get a therapist yeah yeah
so it's good for you and people in your
life betterhelp.com yeah but uh well now
you're making it a commercial i didn't
mean to make it a commercial but uh but
yeah i was just saying like get a
therapist betterhelp.com okay so uh yeah
it's a tough thing man i'm sorry that
that's happening but people can change
and people can can be the person like
you said that you need in their life
in your life and that's an awesome thing
especially you know families grow you
have kids and then they become important
and then
you know they don't want to not have an
uncle right
yeah give it a chance
uh as much as you can but you have your
limit you know where your limit is know
where your limit is going in and then if
he crosses it
cut back out of your life behead him
behead him i've been watching too much
tutors but also matt you know matt
verbally abuses me but i still can't
commit i can still kill him in cow's
life yeah no i do verbally abuse chris
all right cool next
matt hey chris so i got a good one for
you that i think only you can help me
with um
my girlfriend and i the last two years
have kind of been going through a rocky
patch and we spent some time trying to
figure it out and and really diving into
each other and during that time she
bought me crystallia tickets front row
wichita kansas august 27th head on over
to chrisalia.com get your tickets head
on over to the merch page get your oops
button okay i said it so you didn't have
to all right so how do i go about being
like one i kind of still want to save
the relationship and two
i want to get my ass in those seats
no idea even how to go about it like i
really want to go with her
you know
i have no idea what to say to get that
whole process started in the first place
uh maybe you can help me out love you
guys thanks so this guy guys girl got
him tickets
and he wants the tickets he wants to go
but he doesn't necessarily want to go
with her
right do i have this right
oh he does he said he wanted to go there
okay well either way you can't take
someone else
if you have the tickets you got to go
with her also if she has the tickets
you know you got to get a good graces
but i think that um
what is a rocket am i am i wrong when i
say
this guy is having a rocky patch with
his girlfriend
she bought him
tickets to see you in wichita he's
excited to go
and wants to go with her
what's the problem yeah i think that he
is saying that uh he didn't say he
didn't want to go he said he did want to
go it does want to go yeah so i think
that he's
is this [ __ ] just trying to get
on the show i mean maybe no um
i don't know what the
problem is yeah i guess you're right i
guess let's say he doesn't want to go
with her if he doesn't want to go with
her
it doesn't matter you have to go with
her you're having a rocky patch in your
relationship and you want to make things
[ __ ] better that is a way to
absolutely destroy everything oh thanks
honey you got me two tickets to see my
favorite comedian now i'm gonna take my
friend jim and not you bye yeah terrible
yeah there's no way to orchestrate that
yeah i want to go with her then there's
no [ __ ] problem go yeah have a good
time
rekindle the romance have a sex the
night that
you see chris and uh
let chris bring you guys back together
yeah it's a win-win or is she gonna be
you're gonna start some [ __ ] she's gonna
take someone else and then you're gonna
see if she takes it and you're gonna be
like zach pimbro yeah she's gonna go
with zach oh no the guy from depression
is very
um yeah also dude
maybe he's worried about because they've
had a rocky patch like maybe they
haven't talked for a bit you know we
don't know the thing
go with her
go with her here's the deal though if
you're worried about the whole like
awkwardness of it
i got you bro that's what comedians are
for you let me do the heavy lifting
that's what going to a comedy show is
the
best first date you can do yeah it is
the best awkward date you can do
the comedian is doing all of the work
yeah right yeah yeah yes and you're just
sitting there going
right
she's getting all hot because the way
i'm activating no no no right she goes
home hot she doesn't go home with me
yeah but i activated her you welcome
bring a towel okay so you go with two
things a smile and a towel and you leave
my show
and it's hump city you are
yelling it's wrong city dude you are
yelling you want her to throw it back
so that's what's up dude
yeah i mean i'll do the heavy lifting
and it's wrong city for you population
two go with the girl rekindle the
romance
fall back in love uh vis-a-vis crystalia
yeah and fall in love all over again
this august 27th
in wichita yep
so not a lovely place yeah
but um you can also uh [ __ ] outta i had
a i don't know it's e you look you're
either a mexican or a mexican and you're
gonna show up and you're gonna be a
mexican
before the devil knows you're mexico
all right
before the devil knows your wichita
hey so
david here from nashville i just have a
quick uh question for you guys first of
all thank you for all you guys do it's
amazing
amazing show
um i just have a question so my wife and
i have a discussion we're always about
movies
i'm the type of person that does not
like to watch movies more than once
me too let me explain
uh she's the the
opposite she likes to watch movies all
the time and repeat like every time
there's christmas she watches elf and
all these different movies over and over
and over
so my thing is whenever i watch a movie
um i kind of want to get surprised and i
want to
get it you know not know what happens
next and figure out what the movie is
about and then final resolution at the
end of the movie kind of thing
but if i've seen the movie i know what
happened so
it has to be a really really really
really good movie for me to want to
watch it more than once so am i crazy i
don't know what do you guys think i mean
wife changed back dude um
what the [ __ ] was going on in his house
dude he had a kid he's from a magical
beautiful yeah he was doing some kid
[ __ ] yeah um some terrible sounds dude
we're this is us i like to watch a movie
once
here's the thing if she's just like a
person in the world who has nothing her
job isn't to do with movies she's not
like a crazy movie buff or
trying to break him down i can't really
defend her position she just wants to
watch elf over and over again that's
just a human being with a problem the
reason i like to watch it more than once
is is almost always because i want to
see from a craft position how it was
done how this happened how they did that
specific thing whatever it is uh
and so but that's a unique
specific thing to me you know right yeah
i would understand most people
understandably only want to watch thing
i think once maybe twice three times if
they love it but they don't want to
watch the same [ __ ] movie and over
again yeah understandably i mean if
she's a i would say if she's a cinephile
okay but she's watching elf over and
over so basically what you are is a
toddler right that's what gave it away
you're married to a toddler like if
she's watching casino shot by shot yeah
okay she's a cinephile but she's
watching
will ferrell dressed up as an elf yeah
you're a toddler so congratulations
you married a two and a half year old
that's who was making the sounds in the
background right right right two and a
half year old wife yeah
this is i mean put on baby shark and see
what she thinks of that right she'll
flip the [ __ ] out mm-hmm yep
well in this situation buddy you're in
the right and yeah you watch it
sometimes we got to put up with [ __ ]
that we don't want to put up with in
relationships unfortunately for you
that's watching elf a lot honestly
that's not very unfortunate if that's
the thing that you're calling in about
you know it could be it could be way
worse also have you seen elf no i know
it's it's fine
it's
[ __ ] why do you say that
because it's [ __ ] i mean people love
that movie it's fine once and as a
christmas movie it's good once okay okay
okay
the bar is lowered at christmas for
christmas movies fine you know what's
[ __ ] great is that one with uh arnold
schwarzenegger
jingle all the way is great that one is
so [ __ ] funny why don't people talk
about that one more i'm gonna get the
turbo man i think they're starting to a
little bit more it's really it's him
it's sinbad i've been on isn't it
hartman in that [ __ ] philharmonic yeah
yeah yeah rita wilson's new new husband
that's a good cast dude rita was his new
husband
in the movie oh oh oh because his room
died his marriage his relationship is on
the rocks
with his wife and his wife is played by
rita wilson oh yeah her new boyfriend is
phil hartman who is there somebody to
play
a new husband better than phil hartman
no no no nobody was straight up one of
the funniest people ever to exist and
it's such a sad tragedy what happened
it's a tragedy when anyone dies but man
that the stuff that we missed out on
because of how early he died oh my
[ __ ] that guy how
you know what he would have been he
would have gotten so much bigger you
know what i mean yeah because he just
got funnier and funnier as he got older
and he would have just been this old
legend yes you know yes he is and was
had
i mean snl i don't even really like it
that much oh so many of his characters
are in like the top all-time snl things
[ __ ] house guests dude how about him
and sinbad doubling up and house guest
and jingle all the way that was a good
one too those two what's the one where
he says
a surprise
no
[Laughter]
what do you he says
a surprise no
[ __ ] a boat would be a surprise this
is a catastrophe
it's one from one of them yeah probably
oh my god that movie i saw [ __ ]
dozens of times when i was a kid but
then again i was a kid there you go all
right next one
what's up lifeline what's up matt and
chris everybody podcasts and all kinds
all types of ways here's here's the
advice from
we just finished a wedding as you can
see yeah yeah someone gets ratchet
and uh
advice here is do we go to the after
party we don't see our friends very
often we know that uh it's gonna be a
fun time the friendship times but also
it's 2 a.m we're tired as hell yeah what
are you going to do
what do we do
in the world
and get up early tomorrow for the
friendship times
100
none of these guys got laid none of
these guys got laid they also all went
to the after party
that guy was like yeah man i don't even
know what to do just so sexy with his
voice
already
that goes rick fox
already sexy and then when he [ __ ]
talked the girls just go [ __ ] good
wow nobody does that but yeah okay
okay god damn dude after the party is to
after party fomo is not real fomo is a
made-up thing because guess what
the things that you miss out on you
weren't there
so you don't know that it was fun
because you weren't there yeah but you
know what happened because of stories
afterwards the guy in the back dude the
guy in the back was secretly the most
handsome
wow dude secretly um because he didn't
speak up much yeah
uh yeah you don't think fomo is
something i mean i guess it is something
if you feel
nervous about missing out on something
people that like experience it a lot
bugged me out dude i don't like any
coined terms like that i want to make up
my own you know i don't want to use
other people's [ __ ] terms so i would
just say
you know about that the opposite of fomo
yolo get out there and have a good time
i think that basically if it's 2 a.m
if you're okay
if you're under the age of let's say 20
27 or below they were they were in their
20s okay well
they can go then right if they're under
20 27 or under you can go to the after
party that starts at 2 a.m if you're 27
or old or if you're over if you're 28 or
above you cannot go to the after party
that starts at 2 a.m after the party is
the after party if you're under 27 if
you're over 28 you don't go yeah that's
right
said it now we say it right
um i think that um
you went
they definitely went you you went and
you did drugs two of them vomited at 4am
and and one passed out where he wasn't
supposed to and woke up late for his
flight on a bench in front of the house
the only one that made it home safely
was the guy in the back yeah because he
was the most sober right yeah totally
yeah that was unreal that that would
what a good one i want a follow-up from
them yeah let's get one up so let's have
a follow-up from one from that one you
guys try to get even more sexy guys in
it get like
double the amount of 25 sexy men in it
well there were four sex amounts to
eight and then if there's another
follow-up we'll do 16. 12. yeah oh
you're going to keep doubling it don't
kill us okay
um all right um that was a good one that
was a good one i love that one dude that
one was funny immediately just dudes
being dudes you know yeah yeah none of
them got laid no none of them still
haven't been laid since the [ __ ]
video
threw up one of them passed out on a
bench in front of the house where the
after party was
and the black dude got home safely
they'd like to go home safely and and oh
the whole time smelled terrific and then
even into the next day smelled terrific
and didn't take a shower ahead still and
just it smells so good all the time and
had no hangover whatsoever yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh 100 yeah and his favorite
movie is transformers okay
yo chris and matt i'm a big fan
my best friend's gay and he told me that
he had phoenix towards me since day one
okay i was okay with it and i still am
but like he isn't moving on
he knows that there's no chance i'm a
straight guy i have a girlfriend
but also it's kind of difficult for him
because i'm the only male in his life
he's an introvert he doesn't have a lot
of friends geez that's tough and i don't
know what should they do stabbing i
can't see him hurting every time we meet
whoa wow so not should i just not be
friends with him anymore so that he can
move on what should they do
because we talked about this thousands
of times whoa i mean you're not gay
he knows that much love from lebanon
thank you this again i can't stop
worrying but i'm saying he's not gay
that's like you can't you you're not gay
this guy's got to get through his head
you're not a gay man so that can't
happen i think he's gotten it through
his head it's just their best friends so
they do hang out and then when they do
hang out he's like
i'm in love with you so i get i honestly
get why he likes you dude because he's
just like i see him going through so
much pain yeah he's just like such an
empathetic
so so nice uh but i think that that
seems like it's a bit of a dead end if
he just told you once then that's
nothing that's totally chill whatever
you guys move on remain friends you say
well sorry i'm not gay i'm [ __ ]
if i was obviously we're best friends
i'd probably start with you if i was but
i'm just not this is like
he keeps bringing it up
well
that's like if you're in the friend zone
with a woman who you really wanna be
with and you keep trying to date her
she's like at a certain point she's
gonna be like i don't want to and also
you're making me uncomfortable yeah you
can't bro we're not going to be together
you can't keep doing it
yeah it's like going to a [ __ ] auto
shop and you're like dude i'd love to
work on cars and like have you ever
worked on cars and you're like no i
don't know a thing about cars and you're
just like oh you can't yeah okay i like
what i said what i like what i said
better but but i know but my thing is
more i take it to the masses right
because everyone gets their car done
no okay but everyone also has some kind
of amorous feelings for somebody so i
took it to the masses better
love is universal
yeah that's what you're saying yeah
um
so dude i'm sorry but you got to tell
the guy
look i love you you're one of my best
friends maybe my best friend whatever he
said best friend but yeah like i i
you're making it a bit uncomfortable
like i i'm i i can't reciprocate those
feelings for you it's literally my
biological makeup won't allow me to
so like you gotta either get over it or
i don't know can we still be friends
like what yeah what's going on here and
put it on him like have him answer some
questions because it shouldn't be just
you like he should also be like
one would think he should be like i i
don't think i can continue seeing this
guy it's torture
yeah true what i mean yeah you'd be
doing him a favor maybe by being like yo
quit this [ __ ] don't bring it up again
you know yeah and also like maybe also
maybe on the just to be the devil's
advocate maybe try it out you know
you don't have to do like full-on
tummy he might feel pressured that would
be bad i think he would feel like just a
stroke or something okay i know i think
you over the pain i think that that's a
bad idea to pressure to talk yourself
into doing a sexual act that you don't
want to do you know you don't want no no
no no no what i'm saying is what i'm
saying is the guy's flying a little
closer to the sun than we are so maybe
he in a way there is some kind of like
oh maybe i do want to do some otp stuff
don't psychologize i'm not saying
this is lifeline dude and here's the
other thing because and the only reason
why i say this is one time i was having
a conversation with a bunch of people in
montreal
and
somebody was talking about being gay and
every anyone asked
is there any part of any of you that
would ever there was like five of us
that ever thought about that maybe they
were gay
and i was like no honestly no you know i
don't have anything like i'm not like
get penises away from me but like i just
like i
if i try to think about it or wrap my
head around it's just not for me it's
not something i want to do and the guy
next to me said
and
he was australian but i'm not doing it
because but this is what he was and he
was like ah not me mate i'm not gay and
i know that a hundred percent and i was
like that's such a weird way to answer
that
and i said
why did you say it like that he says
because man when i was younger i tried
it once with my friend and it just
wasn't for me
and i'm like
wow so you're saying for some people to
know they have to try it i guess i would
suggest in that case if it doesn't seem
like he is but if that guy's going
through that he should try it with
someone who's not his best friend who's
in love with him and you know you try it
with zach pimbro of depression because
then you go on with his still with his
microphone just like this make it a date
though
you make it a date so you can scratch
that off zach's list hey guys so i don't
want to be doing this but
caught up caught up together i don't
want to be doing this oh anyway
all right um yeah so i that's a tough
situation though it is tough
well you know what i want to say though
props to you yeah for like being
open-minded i mean you know what i mean
like it's it's
if you think oh having a gay best friend
it's of course it's fine
but it's like having a best friend as a
woman if you you're like look i don't
know if i want to be one day dealing
with that whole feelings conversation
you know which you don't always have to
have but it's interesting and even with
the gay thing it's a little bit more
because you're not gay
and he is yeah but props to you for uh
you know
not looking at color
well that's actually not what he's doing
but it doesn't matter what color you're
all good i don't see color when it comes
to well clearly because this has nothing
to do with color let's uh do the last
one more or is that it is that it
there's one more okay let's do it
so handsome my name is
and i'm from the uk beautiful and i
absolutely love this podcast it's my
favorite podcast i love you too it was
congratulations for a good few years
but i could do with some help because
i'm just waiting to pick up my parents
from the airport it's making me think of
my terrible fear of flying is something
that stops me from
seeing my friends on holiday it stops me
from going away with my girlfriend i do
fly but very infrequently
and i also work in the film industry as
a set dresser and we're going to be
uh flying around in the coming months
and i need to be able to kind of
overcome this because i want to do those
things yeah i hate turbulence i'm i've
seen too many films where things go
wrong every movie so i'm a very anxious
buyer and i can really do some advice i
know that you guys fly a lot i'm sure
chris flies a lot with all the shows
um you know do you guys get anxious what
do you do to combat that
any advice or any thoughts around it
would be really appreciated so thank you
very much
do i have a story for you uh no but go
to the last podcast and watch this
beginning
um but i don't usually get anxious so
you should talk about that actually i do
get very anxious a lot of the time and i
used to i used to actually have a
terrible fear of flying right i didn't
go to things that i regret about i
regret now yeah because i was terrified
of being scared i realized that it was
about my ocd and i realized it was about
my uh anxiety and had nothing to do with
actual because here's something that
helped me too like
you on a plane you're scared that
it's gonna crash
okay that's i guess what you're scared
of it's actually egotistical to think
that way because
there's so many other people on this
plane you think you're the guy
that gets to have this happen and it's a
romantic notion dude it's a notion of oh
man i'm going to be on the plane just my
luck i'm scared of turbulence dude it's
not going to happen to you because
and i'm sorry to say this but you don't
matter that much
you're just somebody on an airplane
that's all it is and all of the
airplanes all of them except like one
get to where they're going
you know and you're not on that one and
here's the other thing too
you're going to miss out on [ __ ] which
you already are and that does suck you
are going to regret it because i do
and when i was probably around your age
was when i was most scared of flying but
once i started to wrap my head around
the [ __ ] fact that it's egotistical
and it has nothing to do with me it
really started to help me i still
sometimes do get nervous but also
i think that sometimes it is a young
adult thing because for me i was scared
of flying because i had not made my
quote-unquote mark yet i had not done
some things i wanted to do in my life
with my career i didn't really know who
i was and i
had a fear of like dying prematurely and
it all [ __ ] went out into that okay
i'm on a flight now it could happen now
um
there was a like a few months where i
was terrified driving over bridges
whoa yeah i would just have like a panic
attack i'd speed up and i was making
myself more unsafe by [ __ ] driving
not right too fast over these bridges i
tell you what that's way more dangerous
than flying never is 100 nobody
basically nobody ends up dying in a
plane crash because planes rarely rarely
crash
you're more likely to get [ __ ] hit by
a car waiting for your parents at the
airport and die than you are die in a
[ __ ] plane crash dude it just doesn't
happen and keep that in your mind every
time you hit turbulence every time
something [ __ ] weird happens yeah
you're just not going to [ __ ] die
there's also medication bro that really
ah and there's also medication that
helps way too much like
in matt's uh in match case and then
also um
well there's something else i wanted to
say
i don't know you're just
you're gonna you're fine you're fine
keep flying you're not gonna crash i
promise you if you crash and die i will
give your family a million pounds okay
whatever that is
that's a lot of money okay well no he's
not gonna so oh i got you i see yeah oh
yeah yeah uh uh yeah
uh that's it yeah okay that's it that's
it so yeah so sign up for moment house
it's in the pinned comment below moment
dot co slash lifeline it'll be posted
below though and then also um you can do
that and you can uh
talk with us it's uh gonna be uh
live
lifeline so we can talk back and forth
with you and you will be there on the
phone with us yeah and so why i also you
can uh send a a thing in by
watchlifeline.com
video and then um i'll be in dallas and
wichita and atlanta and washington dc
and savannah georgia and peoria go to
chrislea.com a lot of dates there and
you can get the new merch we got a bunch
of ones we got [ __ ] merch is killing
i've been wearing it all this week we
got the [ __ ] hoodies we got the
t-shirts we got the sweatshirts we got
it [ __ ] oh
yeah go to lifelinemerch.com or
chrisleya.com dude take pics of you in
it when you get it and send them oh yeah
we repost them yeah all right guys
thanks a lot thanks for listening and
what did the guy do
i think it was this
[Music]
hello
[Music]